[Music]
there's no embarrassment
quite like the shame you feel when you
die for the
dumbest reasons imaginable
whether you got hit in the head with a
flashbang or fell off a cliff and
watched helplessly as your bones
crunched into the pavement nothing is as
embarrassing as dying for a
stupid reason so today we wanted to
celebrate those moments where
us and our teammates looked like idiots
because if we're gonna
die like morons well we can at least get
a good laugh out of it
here are the top 10 dumbest ways to die
in esports kicking off our list is
probably
the most humiliating way to die in call
of duty warzone
since the game was released there's been
an endless number of clips making the
rounds featuring some
truly embarrassing deaths
is this yours
[Music]
but of all of them there's nothing quite
like dying in the gulag
not because your enemy killed you but
because some pleb in the peanut gallery
just couldn't resist
shucking a rock at the bouncing betty
that you placed for the enemy
yes you heard me a rock let me show you
why they call me gulag gary
doc watch this play here we go boom
oh oh oh oh he stuns me he runs in for
the kill
the guy threw a rock at my
[Music]
on our list is that moment when the 200
iq play becomes the zero iq play
in rainbow six siege when thermite
places charges on one side of a wall to
open them
defenders like bandit can electrify the
walls to destroy the charges
if timed correctly but when timed
incorrectly
it blows up right in your face and
there's nothing you can do
but look away in shame at the dumbest
way to die
in siege okay so he's not gonna place it
okay he's gonna do the left side
so only esports shouldn't be too worried
about losing this uh
losing that first thermite charge ooh
holding his breath near fighting gets
taken out by the thermite charge fully
blind and just they are unable to get
that banana trick
coming in at number eight is that moment
you know you can get the kill in league
of legends
all you have to do is flash ghost gold
and soaz trying to provide the backup
will he be able to do it pacquiao flash
over the wall and do they have the
damage certainly does to equalize peki
but mighty bear is going to have to back
away turn his attention
back forward now look we've all been
there before you're chasing down what
looks to be an easy kill like the greedy
apr
but wait they're getting away so you
flash in to secure the bag with the hope
of padding those stats
but instead you just flashed into your
own demise
bringing nothing but shame and a lot of
question marks
to your household uh 45 seconds on baron
oh no he doesn't get knocked
he tries to go for the play he goes to
the flash and that ends in his
death
taking the number seven spot on our list
is the most embarrassing way to die
in overwatch whether you're a pro or a
casual
it's falling off the map while using
your own movement abilities
[Music]
unlike other fps games like cs go
overwatch is a game known for its fast
pace and quick movement
so it doesn't come as a shock that most
heroes have an accelerated way of
getting around the map
but used the wrong way things can go
sideways
pretty quickly speaking of good time uh
save you did a little skydiving
uh at the end of that that round can you
tell me what happened here
[Applause]
if you've ever played cs go or any fps
for that matter you've probably felt the
wrath
of fall damage so security imagine that
eyes have fallen
she died of fall damage she died of fall
damage so when you die jumping out of
window or
running off of heaven it's another level
of shame
the enemy team is laughing at you and
your teammates are so shocked that they
don't even know what to say
in the smoke in this one i'm for health
with enough need a bandaid
but seriously guys you're not alone it's
happened to all of us
so for that split second when you're in
the air and realize you've leapt into
your own death
just embrace it and of course on the
verge of taking
the upset ally on one hp running his way
towards the
bomb side and what a way to end that
16-7
what happened there to sunny it must
have been transitioning towards the bend
jumps off he jumps oh he hit the roof he
missed
no that's such a blunder what's he done
that for
coming in at the halfway point on our
list is a dota 2 player's
worst nightmare it's dying to roshan
look we've all seen our fair share of
insane ways to die in dota 2
most of which have been patched out of
the game they're not done mech
still hasn't even been used there's a
hook how
brought all the way back to the base
cleaned up by the fountain but when
we're talking about the dumbest way to
die
there's only one that comes to mind and
there's only one man that can die with
so much grace
and stupidity at the same time almost
over we'll scept her off do the aggro
again
oh didn't get bash not yet
oh god oh my god let me know
oh god again gentlemen and he bought
back the most eternal envy thing
he popped up and he bought back to try
and get through
god
what's worse than getting two stalked
three stalked or even
four stalked in smash there's not a
whole lot that can be more embarrassing
than this one taking the number four
spot on our list
is self-destructing in smash
it pretty much depends on how you're
looking out for it is he gonna get this
no
whoa no oh ice think about it you're in
the middle of a game
your opponent's getting to a high
percentage you can taste blood in the
water
so you go in for a sick combo to cap it
off with style
but wait you just blew the [ __ ] up and
looked like the biggest pleb doing it
juice going out there getting that down
here currently being taken for an entire
ride and
that is not what you want to do
i'm not gonna lie this might be the
craziest oh no
oh wow
yo the heavens just one man y'all to win
[Music]
few have ever lived to tell the tale of
the tragedy that is the number three
entry on our list
and fewer have ever witnessed it but
when it comes to dumb ways to die that
you didn't even know were possible in cs
go
this one takes the cake
getting one tap through a smoke sure
dying from fall damage because you're a
noob
fine but getting killed by a goddamn
flashbang
come on
oh oh cjb
was killed with a flashbang oh wow that
is rare
just going for the quick orc nade with
not a nade
oh no way dude
no [ __ ] way
i just killed him with the flashbang
mega has one health one health whitmer
literally one literally this guy right
here yeah
yeah yeah
taking the runner-up spot is league's
dumbest and most
tragic way to die on the rift oh my god
oh my god he's angry
wait a minute oh my god wait oh my god
look dying to baron or elder dragon is
bad
but those things actually deal a bunch
of damage but when you're farming your
way through the jungle and
die to a measly red buff or gromp come
on
not even dumb and dumber could pull that
off unmolested is possible near the game
i really want to get the jacks going so
he can actually come split before
executed they're in there but now
chasing after the flash comes in
you think he's going another way double
flash the middle here from crystal's
launching
stunts him up dude you can't die to the
raptors in the grand
finals oh no yeah
i mean it's gonna sneak up on you you're
reloading i mean really it could happen
to anyone
one would say
all right we all knew this one was
coming and i can already hear all of you
typing away in the comments about how
you all knew it would be number one on
our list
but look the 1g is the be-all and
end-all
of dumb ways to die and now it's summit
in the 1v1 to try and close this out
against bugley
buggy playing it aggressively no but
it's going to clutch it
and splice will close out map number one
16 to 11 oh wait
what oh no
summit no nothing compares to the
self-inflicted pain of throwing that
molly
nothing compares to the eternity of
shame and embarrassment you've caused
for yourself
as your body burns away for the saddest
and dumbest of deaths
let's move on just move past it all
right it's all audio you know yeah
and he goes down and finis getting wool
back then putting himself
on fire no summit i hope you're watching
the game brother because this
is uh this is one g's at the chat
absolutely
[Music]
no don't worry that was my own molotov
[Music]
god it all right folks that's our list
if you think there's some dumb way to
die that we missed be sure to let us
know in the comments and if you haven't
already
sub to the channel and hey you know
what's not dumb following us on twitch
make sure to head over to twitch.tv
slash the score esports and follow the
channel so you
never miss out on a stream see you guys
next time
in the conversation just like i just
don't find things funny yes
yes it just baffles me it's mystifying
i missed i don't get it i've never
laughed at a movie i'm like [ __ ] hell
i know yeah yeah brian doesn't laugh
though now they think about it like he's
a cheerful dude he just doesn't laugh at
anything
he just makes that fun he just makes the
crow noise when he [ __ ] up
yeah yeah he just he just screeches
[Music]